I'm in the house I grew up in,
in the middle of Fife Scotland.
There's no rational or logical explanation
(laughs)
or any reasonable idea for me to ever
have believed that I'd ever
get to perform on Conan.
And so every time I go, I'm like
"They've made the same mistake
again, this is excellent.
"Let's keep it turning up"
(upbeat music playing)
[JP Buck] A lot of work goes into
a short, late night stand-up set.
Join me, JP Buck as I spotlight
the comedians who came up with
some of my favorite comedy sets.
This is The SetUp.
[Narrator] Please welcome
the very funny, Daniel Sloss.
(upbeat music playing)
First time I heard about
you was at the Fringe
and I didn't get to see you that year,
but I was contacted by your
agent and you were going to
potentially be traveling to the U S.
And so I, without ever having met you,
helped set up a bunch of gigs for you.
I don't know how much you know about this.
And then you actually had to cancel
and you couldn't come over.
I don't know much of that.
Yeah, I think I booked
at like the Ice House
and a bunch of other spots.
Why did I cancel?
Some scheduling issue.
Believe me I was never offended by it.
But the funny thing is
in order to see you,
I couldn't just drive to
Pasadena. I had to get on a plane,
fly to Edinburgh, see you at the Fringe.
And not only get to Edinburgh.
Like, Edinburgh is, you know,
it's a long trip, but staying
at the center of town,
most of the comedy shows
are at this other venue,
different venues that are
pretty close to each other.
Like there's the Pleasance
and there's the Underbelly.
And there's the Leith.
The Harp, yeah
they are all in the same area
The Harp, yeah, yeah
Yeah, yeah
You choose to be another
25 minutes away of a walk
away from those venues.
Yeah.
I land, and then I've
got to walk 25 minutes
out of town to come see you.
You gotta want me baby, you gotta want me
(laughing)
Getting there was totally worth the trip.
It was one of the best
shows I had seen that year.
And I, that night we were like,
let's just figure out a set and do it.
(music playing)
Explain how you put your set together
and what you sent me.
That I just walk around the hotel room
and recorded it to you there.
Yeah.
Oh God.
Like a sociopath.
(music playing)
Older material.
I really struggle to watch
myself any old shows of mine
because I dunno. I just think I'm crap.
Not then, just by comparison.
So I watched this earlier and
I managed to get most of my
cringing out.
(music playing)
For colleagues who haven't done TV before
I say dress slightly better.
You don't have to wear a suit,
but slightly better than
what you would wear on stage.
This is slightly better
than what I wear on stage (laughing)
Hello.
[Audience] Hello
Are we all doing oh well?
[Audience] Yes
Most of us fairly
disappointed that a child
just walked on stage.
(audience laughing)
(clapping)
I didn't even like Home Alone, damn.
(audience laughing)
This was the cut-off point
for that joke working, right.
I'd been doing that joke
since I was 17 years old.
And in this I'm 23.
I was really stretching the child
last drops of the milker
that we're just going, okay.
And I guess I still, you
look, look young there.
(upbeat music playing)
My mom's had four kids.
You can tell that she
loves us all the same,
but after the first two,
she kind of stopped caring.
She'll always go on about,
how she was blessed with me.
Then she was gifted with my sister.
Then she had my brother
(audience laughing)
and she'll always remember the day
that she was diagnosed with the other one.
We need to stop right there.
(laughing)
I'm so excited. I put that
joke in there specifically,
the joke that's about to happen.
I put it in there specifically
because I knew that you were
gonna take it out.
It's a joke that I put in every single set
throughout the years because I know
especially the UK
people wanna edit your set
just so they feel that
you've edited your set.
So you put in something that you know,
is not going to get in.
They take it out, they feel
like they've done their job.
And then they leave the
rest of the set alone.
That is purely the reason
I put that joke in the set.
And you were the first person
when I sent through this set
you were like
"Yeah, I'll fight for it."
And I was like
"There's no way
(laughing)
"There's now way this is
gonna be on the show."
When you said I could,
genuinely, watching it,
watching this clip
the joy on my face, the sheer joy.
And it's a genuine laugh.
And it's such a genuine reaction
of a mischievous child going
(giggles)
I can't believe they let me do it.
We were all intentional
though, which is good.
My mom has a very healthy
outlook to contraception,
which is great because her
sister is anti-abortion,
which is a cruel nickname,
but she's had five.
(audience laughing)
I'm as surprised as you are
that they let me do that joke.
I (laughing)
(audience laughing and clapping)
He Keeps going, hold on, just a laugh
(laughs)
I know, I'm shocked.
(audience laughing)
But that's the moment
where I properly relaxed.
That was just, I can't,
I still can't believe,
I got to tell that joke on
national television in America.
(audience cheering and clapping)
That was great.
Thank you man
That was fantastic.
I enjoyed it.
Daniel Sloss, ladies and
gentlemen, really nice job.
(audience cheering and clapping)
The comment from everyone
was the exact same,
which is when you watch
Gordon coming up to me,
it seems like he's genuinely
surprised that I was good.
Like, he's like,
"That was great. Oh my God,
it's good. The child was funny."
And that it's just me star struck
and bumbling through words like.
"I had a lot of fun.
Thanks for having me."
(upbeat music playing)
One of the kind of ongoing discussions
in the comment section
was your level of attractiveness.
Is it? Really?
No.
Is it?
Yeah, hell yeah, yeah.
I mean, there's one that's right here
It says
"He is probably one of
the hottest comedians
"I've ever seen."
Exclamation point.
I don't read YouTube comments
because I used to read YouTube
comments all the time and, and, and they,
they hurt my feelings. So I was like,
I'll just not do that again.
But now that there's a full on discussion
about how attractive I am
maybe I'll get back into it.
You were like, would
you like to do it again?
And that's just something people say,
or I thought that was just something
I thought that was your legal obligation
to say that after the show
you're like
"Hey well, have you got any time?
(laughing)
"Next time you're in town."
And then, yeah, it's just, I mean, for me,
and I'd like to use this as
an opportunity to say this
I've been doing this work,
my first set was 2013, was it?
December 2013?
Conaco and Conan have been
so immensely supportive
over my career.
Like the fact that,
you know,
you did take a small young
comedian from the other side of
the world and you took a risk on them.
You let them go on stage. Not
only did you, let me go on TV,
you let me do the material
that I wanted to do.
You really tried your
hardest to not edit it.
And then everyone backstage,
from the,
from the crew to the camera crew,
to the runners,
and it's just a joy to do.
And then every time I
go back, it's just, eh,
it's something I never expected
the chance to get to do
multiple times. And every time
I go back, it's just such a,
I don't know, a home away
from home and a pleasure.
So just thank you so much for ever
allowing me to be part
of this insane thing.
It's been, it's a pleasure for all of us
and we love having you,
and you're part of the family.
Thanks again for doing this and
can't wait to see you soon.
Love to you all.
Thank you all very, very much.